[Music]
how would you describe your chest style
um
i think it depends on my mood okay
actually
[Music]
sometimes i want to play aggressive
sometimes i want to to make a quick draw
so like this probably now what is your
biggest strength in chess
i would say a
positional positional plane maybe
but um
i don't know about this i just playing
like
whatever
how about weakness then
oh that's a lot
i don't believe that
i don't like how my memory works
sometimes
yeah because
i don't remember some lines
in the opening which i actually have to
have to remember
but sometimes i remember some stupid
things but i don't remember
like my
my
favorite opening or something like this
yeah ah it's a relief to hear that that
happens to jesus as well but okay what
would you say is your most successful
opening then italian italian opening
but
i thought that italian before the game
here against
giri
[Music]
where i lost so now i'm not sure which
is which is my most successful